I've been bit naughty I've changed my
topic I want to start off by sharing
with you one of my absolute favorite
inspiring people Jacob Randolph steer
hope you've heard of him the ascent of
man is the series that he made this is
episode 2 and in episode 2 he stands on
the island of Samos which is where
Pythagoras was born and talks about
Pythagoras and he starts to do a
demonstration with tiles for the
Pythagorean theorem and once he's done
this he stops and he says in his
beautiful method of delivery he says now
we have a square on the hypotenuse and
we can of course relates that by
calculation to the squares on the
shorter sides and then he has a kind of
a bit of a wing to the camera and he
says but we don't need in the
calculation a small game and then he
pauses such as children and
mathematicians play will transpose a
triangle here and a triangle there and
then he shows the game and so my talk is
called games played by children and
mathematicians young children are not
afraid to experiment they're not afraid
to ask why I always ask my students very
mature serious students to think about
their younger brothers and sisters who
go while I fly one why and young
children also demonstrate surprising
concentration skills when they work on
problems so I believe it's really
important to bring childishness back
into high school
a firm believers here's one of my
favorite childish time blessings I hope
you've seen this one by hearts wind mr.
oak if you haven't please look at it
today when do mr. I'm it is a very
intriguing narrative it's sense-making
challenge as a childish game played on a
mobius strip it has a surprise twist as
a motivation to explore and has really
deep mathematics beneath it it's an
instant 30 minute lesson you just need a
bit of paper a bit of blue and you can
replicate this every single time I've
done this lesson students go home and
they tell their parents they tell their
brothers they tell their sisters even
better the next day they come and tell
me I liked by heart so much I found this
one whom I don't doodly okay there's
many lessons on doodling so if I heart
really invokes that sense of play and
there's a role for it in your high
school mathematics classroom I believe
we need more paper folding it's not
enough paper following the school that
I've just gone to that I've just moved
to very high performing academic classes
I've discovered my year 12 cannot fold a
square cannot create a square out of a
four piece of paper they just haven't
done any paper folding so we definitely
need more of it um here's my favorite
one I learnt this from Peter Hickey I've
written up about it on my blog you can
actually demonstrate in the floors with
a piece of a4 paper and then you can
take it the next level and ask your
students to think about negative folds
and origami and actually do the [ __ ]
if index powers it's great fun in most
functions you can have a terrific time
with pen and paper so what you need is
rip a square a piece of paper that was
the challenge for my year 12 to create a
square piece the edge canceled and a
coin trick here is there is unique coin
is you getting to create a square piece
of paper they fold it on a diagonal you
get them to do a very accurate graph in
lead pencil quite heavy on the lid then
you get them to fold and you take the
coin and you scratch the lid off and of
course it does the reflection this is an
activity are we all talk a bit more
about this later vihart again has got
the most beautiful paper folding proof
of Pythagoras and while she's also i'll
mention she has also got a fantastic
animation showing what happened to the
guy who discovered that the square root
of two is irrational what's a great way
to learn about circles use circles it's
amazing how many kids don't touch paper
circles a fantastic asset that you need
in your classroom teach circle geometry
with circles some beautiful ways to do
it and this is an exploration that
you'll see often done only in lower
achieving classics let's do a paper
folding method paper cutting method of
looking at the area of circle I think
it's a suitable for a calculus plus you
can extend this lesson to all your
calculus concepts I bet every student
should do this act should do this
activity nothing beats childishness
better than Sesame Street this is my all
time favorite sublime video it's called
fish fish fish i'll give you the links
at the end i show this to my year seven
classes i show this to my year 12
classes it's got content all the way
from the sublime to the ridiculous James
Blunt singing you're so beautiful to the
tune of you're so beautiful about his
love for an equilateral
trial it's hysterical um the best thing
my year 10 class and i have done is
watch a year 5 video called i'm a
parallelogram it's the most addictive
song that you'll ever see and it just
has such a sense of fun into the drama
trip really recommend that one one sense
of fun in your classroom this guy you
want miss buying your class dr. james
groans does a lot of things on a channel
called a youtube channel called number
file every week there's two or three
things that is just so exciting you can
build short lessons one lessons it's
amazing how it links into the curriculum
and how it extends this one is the
mathematics from Good Will Hunting those
of you have seen the movie now that he's
a cleaner and he's got to solve a
problem and this is the problem that he
sold whether you can bring this problem
into your classroom do it it's a great
an entire exercise okay is this just
math attainment which is what some of my
colleagues is to accuse me of doing is
it matter tainment well let's have a
think about this lesson introduces
students to topology these Sesame Street
videos can actually introduce lessons
and discussions on abstraction what
we're actually doing in mathematics I
got this idea from a guy called Steven
strogatz is one of the top mathematics
riders in the world if you look up on
google from fish to infinity he's the
one who pointed at this video as it
would starting point the number theory
our hearts work is terrific she always
asks deep mathematical questions at the
end and challenges the kids you've
folded something is it true how do we
know that it's not just an artifact of
folding so really good questions there
so deep thinking about proof any moment
won't you the site is good narrative go
faster is this just for little kids
absolutely not I find that many of the
higher achieving classes or senior
classes have never done these types of
activities they love them you've just
got
instant to touch the paper once they do
they love them what's even better is
you'll be amazed what they do to your
idea of what you're going to do in the
lesson they carry on way further than
you ever imagined so it's very rewarding
um my goals for an inner child lesson
must be engaging there must be something
students do so don't just watch a video
it's got to be something you can stop
and pause and do something with an
extent and it must have potential for
extensions why else is a good kids get
to see your inner child come out I think
that's what you wanted something that
Eddie was saying about you've got to
share that passion and inner child
activities give you a chance to do that
one last line Homer Simpson visits the
land chocolate and goes wild and
imagines how beautiful world would be
was just made of chocolate Seymour
puppet one of the great educators
encouraged us to create a place called
math ledge and he said if students lived
in Backlund they would have no
difficulty learning maths and so his
challenge is us how can we create math
ledge that's what it's really about
I